y
[Música]
la policía de texas reconoció su
respuesta tardía y los veo en un colegio
de uralde que dejó veintiuna personas
muertas en paralelo y desde la
convención de la asociación nacional del
rifle houston el ex presidente de
donación dijo que la existencia de la
maldad no era una razón para desarmar a
los ciudadanos
cuba acogió el encuentro de la cumbre de
los países del alba durante el evento
los integrantes de la alianza rechazaron
la decisión de eeuu de excluir a
nicaragua y a venezuela de las cumbres
de la cumbre de las américas que se
celebrará dentro de unos días en los
ángeles
argentinas confirmó dos casos positivos
de la viruela del mono ambos pacientes
contrajeron la enfermedad en españa
donde se concentra un gran número de
contagios argentina es el primer país de
américa latina en reportar casos por
esta enfermedad tenemos reporte desde
buenos aires
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz
empezamos en eeuu las autoridades
locales de texas admitieron el grave
error en su respuesta frente al tiroteo
en la escuela primaria rock en balde a
principios de esta semana y que dejó 19
niños y 2 maestras muertos las
autoridades se entregaron más detalles
de lo ocurrido mientras se enfrentan a
crecientes cuestionamientos sobre el
tiempo que los agentes tardaron en
responder a la situación más en el
siguiente informe
19 agentes durante más de 40 minutos
esperaron afuera del aula donde salvador
ramos mató a tantos niños como policías
esperaban fuera el viernes el director
del departamento de seguridad pública de
texas dijo a los periodistas que el
comandante en la escena creía que ramos
estaba atrincherado solo en el aula a
pesar de los disparos esporádicos y a
pesar de que varias llamadas fueron
hechas al 911
por supuesto que no fue la decisión
correcta fue la decisión equivocada
apuntó no hay excusas para eso pero de
nuevo no estaba allí pero sólo te digo
por lo que sabemos creemos que debería
haber habido una entrada tan pronto como
sea posible cuando hay un tirador activo
las reglas cambian ya no es ok ya no es
sujeto en trinchera dow no tienes tiempo
en el sabio
sus declaraciones no sirvieron para
calmar las preguntas de los periodistas
la policía se enfrenta al escrutinio
sobre cuánto tiempo transcurrió antes de
que los agentes irrumpieron en el aula
al menos dos de los niños que llamaron
al 911 sobrevivieron dijo mccraw pero no
está claro cuántos infantes murieron
mientras los oficiales estaban fuera
cuántos estudiantes murieron en esos 48
minutos
no tengo esa respuesta lo estamos viendo
ahora mismo
a unos cientos de kilómetros en houston
los manifestantes se agolparon frente a
la convención anual de la asociación
nacional del rifle en el rey que este
año está perseguida por el espectro de
la masacre nibaldi
y termino la primera jornada de la
convención de la poderosa asociación
nacional del rifle en houston texas el
encuentro al que se espera asista más de
55.000 personas reúne a personalidades
que apoyan el porte de armas en eeuu el
ex presidente de donald trump habló ante
la convención acusó a los demócratas de
politizar el tiroteo en un balde y
arremetió contra sus esfuerzos por
controlar la venta de armas y
la existencia del mal en nuestro mundo
no es una razón para desarmar a los
ciudadanos respetuosos de la ley que
saben cómo usar sus armas y pueden
proteger a mucha gente la existencia del
mal es una de las mejores razones para
armar a los ciudadanos respetuosos de la
ley de ustedes
pasamos a ucrania porque continúan los
combates en la región del donbass y hay
preocupación de que las ciudades
capitales de la región sufran la misma
situación que la asediada mariupol y los
ataques se concentraron en la última
jornada en dos urbes clave severodonezk
y la cercana lysychansk las últimas
controladas por ucranianos en la
provincia de lugansk mientras tanto en
la mano ubicada en la provincia de
donges las tropas ucranianas luchan para
conservar el control de las zonas
noroeste y suroeste ante el avance de la
guerra el presidente volodin excellence
que reconoció que aunque no desea hablar
con su homólogo ruso vladimir putin
tendría que hacerlo para darle fin al
conflicto y yepes su órbita hay cosas
que discutir con el líder ruso no estoy
diciendo que tengamos muchas ganas de
hablar con él quiere subrayar que no hay
muchas ganas pero tenemos que enfrentar
las realidades de lo que somos que
estamos viviendo y lo que viviremos
ustedes se han preguntado que queremos
de este encuentro todos queremos
recuperar lo nuestro queremos recuperar
nuestra vida volver a la vida normal
queremos recuperar la vida de un país
soberano queremos la evolución de
nuestro territorio
vamos a hablar con noticias de américa
latina' líderes de los países del alba
se reunieron en cuba para rechazar la
decisión de eeuu de excluir a venezuela
y a nicaragua de la cumbre de las
américas los integrantes de la alianza
mostraron su apoyo a estas naciones y
calificaron la no invitación como un
retroceso histórico en las relaciones
hemisféricas
el presidente venezolano nicolás maduro
agradeció a sus homólogos quienes en una
muestra de solidaridad decidieron no
acudir al evento mientras que el
mandatario boliviano luis arce dijo que
no puede llamarse una cumbre de las
américas si no están invitados todos los
países del continente el anfitrión
miguel díaz canel criticó a washington
por lo que calificó como prácticas
hegemónicas y antidemocráticas nuestra
américa cambio ya no son posibles las
exclusiones la decisión de no invitar a
todos es un retroceso histórico y todos
los países deben ser invitados en
condiciones de igualdad
es irrespetuoso y lesivo a la soberanía
de las naciones pretender decidir desde
la privilegiada condición del anfitrión
quienes las representan
frente a los intentos de exclusión y
selectividad urge afianzar los
mecanismos auténticos de integración y
concertación latinoamericanos y
caribeños ahora nos vamos hasta buenos
aires porque las autoridades sanitarias
de argentina confirmaron ya dos casos de
la viruela del mono este es el primer
país de américa latina que ha anunciado
positivos por la enfermedad mientras que
vecinos como ecuador y bolivia analizan
casos sospechosos la ampliación de esta
noticia con nuestro corresponsal natalio
cos hoy toda la información que tenemos
viene del ministerio de salud de la
nación de argentina son dos casos como
decía es el primero es una persona que
vino a la provincia de buenos aires- un
residente de la provincia de buenos
aires- que se acercó un efector de salud
porque tenía sospechas el día domingo
pasado tenía pústulas en diferentes
partes del cuerpo tenía fiebre un primer
un primer examen un primer testeo dio un
inicio inicial de que seguramente sería
positivo el día
y se confirmó luego en estos días el día
viernes que el mediante técnica de pcr
que efectivamente era era un caso
positivo y el hombre tenía antecedentes
de viaje a españa donde estuvo hasta el
16 de mayo de 2022 el otro caso también
viene de españa es una persona que
reside en ese país y está de visita en
la provincia de buenos aires- también se
confirmó este viernes por pcr había
llegado el día miércoles 25 de mayo y el
26 empezaron sus síntomas ambos se
encuentran en buen estado general
aislado reciben tratamiento y sus
contactos estrechos se encuentran en
seguimiento clínico y epidemiológico de
estricto según como digo información del
ministerio de salud de la nación de
argentina y nuevamente las calles de
santiago la capital chilena fueron el
escenario de protestas estudiantiles
para exigirle al gobierno del presidente
gabriel boric educación pública gratuita
y de calidad los manifestantes le
pidieron al mandatario que destina del
presupuesto nacional varios subsidios
alimentarios y fondos para mejorar la
infraestructura de las escuelas públicas
existentes las manifestaciones
terminaron en choques con los
carabineros
cañones de agua para dispersar a los
manifestantes que a su vez prendieron
fuego a un autobús
y parís se preparan para la final de la
champions league que se jugará este 28
de mayo este sábado el liverpool donde
juega el colombiano luís díaz se
enfrentará al real madrid en el stade
france
su objetivo es vengar la derrota sufrida
a manos del conjunto español en la final
de 2018 les contamos cómo se prepara la
capital francesa para este partido de
fútbol
restan pocas horas para el partido y los
fanáticos del fútbol se están alistando
para la final de la champions league
este 28 de mayo en la que el liverpool
se enfrentará al real madrid' en los
suburbios del norte de parís el equipo
inglés buscará cerrar una temporada
notable y además vengar la derrota
sufrida ante el real madrid en la final
del año 2018 los aficionados del club
español confían en una nueva victoria el
real madrid- ya tuvo momentos difíciles
esta temporada a pesar de eso siempre
salimos victoriosos así que aunque el
liverpool tiene un gran equipo creo que
realmente podemos ganar esta copa
de acuerdo con las autoridades francesas
se espera la presencia de hasta 40.000
aficionados del liverpool sin entrada
pero solamente 20.000 fanáticos de cada
club tienen asientos asegurados en el
estadio angola voy a mirar a ver si
puedo conseguir un boleto pero
obviamente no voy a pagar demasiado no
pedimos cuál es el plan si no tienes
boleto buscar un lugar en parís y ver el
partido en la televisión como muchos
otros watch game el stade france fue
renovado para la ocasión desde españa 24
camiones transportaron el césped que fue
colocado en 48 horas acceso en campo
híbrido es un césped sintético en el que
se ha cultivado hierba natural lo que
permite tener un campo reforzado de
forma natural
originalmente este partido estaba
programado para celebrarse de san
petersburgo pero fue trasladado a parís
luego de que rusia fue apartada del
encuentro por la invasión a ucrania
hasta aquí este informativo en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]